[Applause]
yes it is our final day in the Honda
studio here in Miami the big game is
just two days away and we have a
big-time show for you here on the Rich
Eisen show Christian McCaffrey Pat
McAfee - Oh we'll be here Deontay Wilder
will be here Joe burrow will be here and
I am thrilled to have a regular guest
from this Rich Eisen show one would say
guest ology my friend my longtime friend
my diehard cheats friend a man who has
told me so many times I would love to
come to the Superbowl and hang with you
but I will not until the Chiefs and the
Chiefs have made it and Eric Stonestreet
is here on the Rich Eisen show there
they are all rich now I would introduce
you as an Emmy award-winning actor but
you are our Honda Report Chiefs insider
to kick off I love it honestly because
you you were you have been around the
team a little bit late I have been
around the team this season you know
I've become friends with Brett Veatch
and he's Vegeta welcomed me in the GM to
the family and I certainly don't try to
take advantage of that sure relationship
because I don't want to be burdened with
knowing things much but he's definitely
giving me a sneak peek and I will tell
you this Chiefs fans football fans Brett
Veatch was on Patrick mahomes from the
very beginning a Patrick mahomes at
Texas Texas Tech and Brett Veatch told
me this year that we would take a
picture with the Lamar Hunt trophy in
the locker room of Arrowhead and we did
that and he said that from the beginning
multiple times so now that is what we
call an insider an insider that's a
that's an insider - but I look I've
known you for a long time if I'm not if
I'm not mistaken you are a mixed
of ecstatic excitement yep and profound
nervousness right yeah I call it
measured I measure I am I am a I am a
volcano of emotions inside this right
now right now like you are you know
because I don't I don't like to get the
cart you know before the horses type of
guy I'm not I know the 49ers are a good
team I also know we're a good team
I love that about this Super Bowl it's a
great matchup we each have things we
have to do to win the ballgame we have
to stop their run and Patrick mahomes
has to be Patrick Malone's there's no
doubt about it and in terms of being
Patrick mahomes you are particularly
tight with some offensive linemen on
this team yeah that we've had so many
analysts come on and sit in this chair
this week Eric and say the offensive
line for the Chiefs versus this
defensive line of the 49ers that is the
matchup of Super Bowl 54 and I'm
wondering what these guys are thinking
as they go into this game because they
know it they're professional athletes
they welcome the challenge I know that
for a fact and I know this is their
moment and this is their time and every
single weight they've lifted every
single drop a sweat they've shed every
single drop of blood they've dripped is
for this moment right now and I don't
have to tell them that they know that
Mitchell Schwartz is ready for Bosa
fishers ready for D for wherever they
line up we're ready for them they got
their ski yeah they're coming that's me
I gotta get I gotta get going back
they're coming for their comfort they're
sensing my activated right now and
they're like we should just follow
Stonestreet around this weekend you
ready to hit somebody yeah I'm ready to
hit somebody man I mean I'll live
vicariously through those guys and I
know a lot of Chiefs fans get to you
know live vicariously through me for
some of the things that I get to do
and I'm proud to be a fan that gets a
microphone and a camera in front of me
every once in a while and get to do
things for the fans and I'm sensitive
because this is not about me right this
is about the Kansas City Chiefs but you
you represent the fan base you and Rudd
and so many other free try you know I
mean Riggle and it is it is just amazing
seeing you know this moment for you
knowing how much it means to you that
you're actually here at a Super Bowl
this is actually good I couldn't believe
it going down there on the field after
that and high-fiving those guys and them
and just just the fact that Veatch told
me you're gonna come down on the
sidelines and you're gonna go in the
walker yeah and you're gonna kiss a
little more hunt trophy with me and that
happening and he said brother brother
the next trophy were gonna kiss is the
Vinny we kissed the Lamar let's get the
Vinny
kiss the Vinny kiss the Vinny I like
that in that great we should make like a
bumper sticker out of like and this is
I'm rocking this right now for Andy
you've got the yeah but the Hawaiians
went to the mall before I left LA and I
said you know what I got to represent
Andy in the best way I can and I
couldn't think of a better way than to
rock a Hawaiian shirt to Miami Eric
Stonestreet here on the Rich Eisen show
and then you were you were Randy read
this year Randy read in handy read
younger brother jet ski salesman right
Oxnard California you know if you know
it did you like yeah obviously had to
clear that with Andy before you did this
yes all right he said yes and I said
look we can't do this unless Andy will
be a part of it right and I don't want
to I don't want to ask that but him
being a part of it will ground it make
it real believable break and fun and he
did it Andy Reid is all time man he is
just did you hear his soundbite talking
about his green support his nine
grandchildren make them young and make
them old yeah at the same time it's a
breeze
[Applause]
drew brees in the house through breezes
here break up the party no no what you
you make the why Hawaii brother we met
right there okay the modern family we
were shooting episodes and the Players
Association was meeting met you Scott
Fujita Matt light in the lobby of the
four seasons
that's exactly right awesome dude man
had a great time that's just
non-throwing art that's great so you're
a fan of modern family back in the day
and you got to just meet Eric
Stonestreet right here yeah that was up
to the first season that was right as
they were just taken off that's pretty
cool having jewelry said you're my guy
yeah it's really good so I don't know if
you know about the Chiefs are in the
Super Bowl
yeah and I'm a Chiefs fan and I said I
would never come to the Super Bowl until
the Chiefs were in it so this is my week
drew I've been waiting for this week so
clear it all up yeah I got to say I'm
glad I'm not playing Drew Brees though I
am I mean I wish nothing against you but
your Midwest guy yeah oh yeah yeah my
first acting job ever professionally
just was shot at Purdue University now
on the football field at Purdue was that
was that was football NCAA college
football it was Joe football shot a
bunch of football commercials and we
shot on my Purdue University and then
you beat us in the Holiday Bowl Kansas
State you you kicked our butts yeah well
it got a subtle greatness from Purdue
University that you just don't know
about until it yeah I mean come on now
yet cradle of astronauts the cradle of
astronauts that's right yep I didn't
know what a great improv team I was on
in the night
have you ever get you've guessed it on
shows recently I just saw you did an
undercover boss right I saw that right
yeah did you ever do a comedy have you
ever done a sitcom or anything like no I
have it I have it I haven't gone the
comedy route yeah I I feel like in order
to kind of expand my kind of my talent
right because I mean Peyton's been on
your show kind of idea was locked
everyone out we have two more episodes
so we can't have you on this season
it'll be you could come on my next show
I would love to I don't know that's
gonna be oh yeah you come up with the
next show no I was gonna say do we know
what that is you know we don't you know
we just got to get through the Superbowl
first we got to get through this week
can we ask drew who eats bikes at a
Super Bowl drew who do you like in the
Super Bowl you can say the 49ers you
know listen I I would love I would love
to see Andy Reid good a Super Bowl ring
yeah he deserves it plus plus I can say
that the last Super Bowl that the Kansas
City Chiefs won was coached by Hank
Stram Purdue grad Dawson Purdue Purdue
grad so boy your mind your first
television job is show football at
Purdue Ross aid stadium oh so I was
painted with I was painted red
my body was painted red and blue for
that job and they put me up at this
hotel and I took a shower the night you
know I was there for two days shoot and
I took a shower got all the makeup off
me but the next morning I woke up and
there was this perfectly read this
perfectly white shadow of my body
landing in the bed because I didn't get
all the makeup on and I thought about
that pork cleaning person that was
coming in after that and just saw all
these this red on the sheets of like
what in the hell
up in here it's like shooting a
commercial shooting commercial exactly
guys paint it or is pretty funny Eric
Stonestreet and Drew Brees kind of have
to sit down here you're here part of
FedEx correct is that what you're doing
you're yeah well I really am just here
to hang out with you guys man by the way
I just want to make sure you know that
we're all we're all good so what's going
on with you you're you're just hanging
out with family yeah I just I just flew
in from the Pro Bowl I saw that yeah
that was fun that's fun your kid was
hang with with Lamar listen the moment
we got there he's like where's Lamar
Jack says that right like I don't know
let's post something on Instagram tell
me you're looking for sure enough two
hours later we see him and boom I love
all that stuff when you broke that
record your family out there I was
you're great you're great guy great for
the NFL great human being they love this
guy my boys it is so much fun to bring
my boys around the locker room and just
bring them around the Pro Bowl and have
them see some of the guys that they look
up to and it's it's it's really one of
the great things about me still being
able to play right to watch them enjoy
it so much
so is that that's another reason to
that's on the list of reasons to the
team this way for sure I'm sorry so go
ahead go drew what are you guys doing
next fall with your family gonna be
particularly well
he's big no son he's playing he's dream
he's got one more two more how old are
you
41 dude Europe I'm 48 48 how many more
you got left in you I got two more weeks
of Modern Family
and then me and drew we're good let's do
a detective show a football detective
show that yeah I like that now which
one's the good cop he's the good piece a
good guy man who's like eighteen oh yeah
I like that I love the 18 yeah I love it
I want to play when a plan comes
together
you know wait where'd you grow up Austin
Texas Austin that's right Allen boots I
bought myself a pair of ostrich by the
way he is jumping out of his skin right
now like literally I've known this man
for a long time yeah in the strike and
just just he mean if kid couldn't happen
literally right now I mean you don't
remember when you went to the Super Bowl
I feel absolutely so what are the next
few days for you partying no a lot of
partying drew no we're just here my
girlfriend and I are here we're having
fun we're going to the Commissioner's
party tonight you're gonna be there I'm
[Laughter]
going to that you know and then tomorrow
I'm going to the yeah okay you throw in
the wheels up party you'd be maybe I
mean are you leaving town and like yeah
I am gonna stay for the game so you are
what Oh
you get to watch the game with Joe
Montana and Brett Favre a cool piece
that we're doing and we're gonna we're
gonna comment on the game now what's
this about what do you mean you're gonna
comment on the game you're gonna just
sit there and we're gonna we're gonna
we're gonna analyze the game and and and
and talk through it and just as three as
three cubies just hanging out on the
couch
and then when do we get to watch you
guys watch that yeah when do we get to
see that oh okay secret
see that's the insider returning right
here yeah sweet can't do it off mic like
I know I mean oh that's pretty cool
so you have three you guys are gonna go
watch that thing yeah we went to the
legends thing last night walked in who'd
we see walked in Jim Brown first player
we sees Jim Brown walk in Orlando
Orlando pace right right then we see Ted
Hendricks Rob Gronkowski walk in Brett
Favre's to the left I mean it's like I
was just saying who are your like
Alzheimer's well I'm a Chiefs fan
through and through my all-time favorite
players are Kansas City Chiefs you know
when we were there
Oh Willie Lanier you talked to Willie
Lanier he's a beautiful beautiful mind
and soul just the way he talks about the
game is so so fun but I grew up in the
90s so we're talking about Albert Lewis
Kevin Ross Neil Neil Smith Derrick
Thomas tan Sally and moola but I'm an
old wine guy
I like oh my favorite player wishes John
all growing up I like the guys that
protect you that's my nature if I would
have been a football player I would have
won to been an offensive lineman I want
to get in the fray and the fact on other
people's behalf Eric Fisher dousing
himself with two beers man and just
saying they've just thrown around like
that's right up your alley
yes directly out of your plate just
Swartz has a great quote about that once
he found out he wasn't athletic enough
to be a defensive lineman he said I'll
take a pay cut and be an offensive
lineman but I love the offensive one so
now you got a love Marty shot I love
Marty ball Marty's my guy loved Marty
shot he was your first car cost me for
four years of San Diego already had a
huge influence on my career I love the
man I wish Marty was with us and
deserves to be in the Hall of Fame
yeah absolutely I'm gonna make that
pitch right now Marty Schottenheimer
deserves to be in the Hall effect
Marty shot better than later
by the way I agree with you there's no
the greatest coaches of all time well
ask anyone who played former coach with
at Bill Cowher who's just getting in was
hired by Marty Shaw who says he said I'd
like to thank Marty Schottenheimer for
giving me an opportunity yeah his
speeches had his motivations were
incredible here in a you know on replay
but here and I mean first first person
must must have been incredible I got to
work with him for two years on
SportsCenter ring was just parts right
worked with him on SportsCenter for a
couple years to I really enjoyed meeting
him like a good good man good dude
real good he's intense loves ball who is
your favorite player growing up good
question so I grew up in Texas
obviously right so my my teenage years
were the Cowboys heyday right Troy
Emmitt Troy my Michael Irvin Jay Novacek
all those guys so that dynasty that that
run I love Joe Montana he I love Joe
Montana except for the fact he went to
Notre Dame by the way you and I are plus
one where we're we're simpatico with the
whole Notre Dame so I rent Rudy hoping
he pulls a hamstring at the end
like literally wish that that would
happen that's how much I despise Notre
till Montana no I loved your months yeah
no I just you know I hate Notre Dame
Notre Dame shot I gotta go oh yeah
Michigan yeah that's correct you can go
right that's a Michigan go blue right
there so that Cowboys offensive line the
Great Wall that's what they call it
right right yeah we can you name them
okay left to right we got a pretty blue
eyes mean Hawaiian guy well to an A to B
was to me on the right
Goggan Kevin golden right Larry Allen
yeah Nate knew Nate Newton step nice key
yeah and all time
left tackle what's his name well it's
it's Eric Williams and it was Eric
Williams Eric Williams there yeah we're
talking Cowboys Cowboys Willie Roaf was
Saints the rope was the initiate that
though probably go left tackles wall
just everybody wants to get in drew
brees information hey man thanks for
popping by yeah it's great to see you
thanks for having me I mean I kind of
just know myself listen your this is
your world this is I'm just I'm just a
spectator to you this your world no it
is not well this is this is the last
quarterback to win a Super Bowl in this
town and the next quarterback to win a
Super Bowl in this town will be named
what do you think Patrick mahomes and in
that regard we want to give you this
shirt that will look really tight the
commissioners party tonight that's Eric
Stonestreet right here on the Rich Eisen
show in his Honda insider report is
brought to you by the 2020 Honda
Ridgeline this tailgate of all-star
features a dual action tailgate a
lockable in bed trunk and an available
truck bed audio system to start
tailgating like you meetings heads your
Honda dealer and check out the ridgeline
today thanks for coming pop in and say
hello to your lovely wife and your
family for me will you please
absolutely and I'm you know I'm gonna be
there for you tonight I'll see you at
the party yeah I'm gonna give you a hug
at the party these I'll uh
I don't know if they'll be there I'll be
part of the waitstaff you're part of the
waitstaff but no I said chill I'll bring
you a drink that's the way you like your
your drinks it's chilled I'll be there
I'm gonna hug let's I'll be there for ya
until kickoff and then and then I wish
you nothing but the best of luck I know
you want it I know how I know you know
how much this all belongs to me gosh I
don't think I've talked about it with
anybody more than you I know that and
they can't believe that it's finally
it's here it's here and I know what a
ball of nerves you are honey mom and dad
okay there you go
don't see here chillin oh yeah first
ballot hall-of-famer to be one day drew
brees right
it doesn't show for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
on DirecTV for free on BR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app